Put on your walking shoes and experience all our city centre has to offer.
Report to Calgarians.
Finding your way in the city centre.
Calgarians and our visitors have a new tool to explore the downtown area.
Wayfinding signage located throughout the city centre...
...tells people where they are, what's around them, and how to get there.
Easily navigate the downtown area whether you're on foot, bike or transit.
Better yet, spend some time exploring Calgary City Centre.
Check out diverse areas like Chinatown, East Village and the Beltline communities.
The new wayfinding signs highlight how walkable our city centre is.
And now, it's even easier to find your way...
...to many attractions in the downtown area.
Your final destination might be closer and more walkable than you think.
So come and experience the economic, cultural and social hub...
...that is our city centre.